join that in the studio by the transport
secretary Mark Harper Mr Robert lovely
to have you in here um but but shall we
start with this does this deeply damning
uh report from the Police Inspector
incredibly worrying not least of course
because of Sarah Sarah everard and and
repeated instances of misogyny within
the police force what needs to happen
for the police to get their house in
order well well look first of all I
think it's worth remembering this report
was commissioned by pretty Patel when
she was home secretary in the wake of
the Sarah everard absolute murder
um and it does contain a very worrying
number of findings
um and I think it's a real wake-up call
for chief constables across the country
so I mean what the government hopes is
that those Chief constables uh and you
know the National Police Chiefs Council
will look at this report and every force
will look at their practices how they
recruit officers you know how they run
their disciplinary processes and make
the necessary changes to improve
standards so the public have the
confidence in the police force that that
is the key point isn't it when you have
the inspector it's saying that there are
hundreds perhaps thousands of bad apples
and we're being very mild to the
language of their bad apples it seems
almost impossible to me that you can
restore confidence in the police until
that situation is entirely resolved well
I think the first thing is yes the
report is has a number of concerning
findings but on the other hand the
positive thing is it's much better that
we understand the scale of the challenge
we understand what the problems are
that's the first thing you have to do to
be able to fix them and the Home
Secretary has made it very clear that
this is an important priority for her
it's an important priority for uh
government but but ultimately this is up
to Chief constables and they've now got
the information in front of them and the
government will expect them to act on
the the recommendations and the findings
of the report and the government will do
what it can to support them in
delivering that so the public can have
the confidence in the police force that
they need indeed it would run us to have
the transport secretary and then not
talk about your brief we'll do that just
a little later in the interview but
think we need to start with with manston
currently what is the situation in there
the latest on numbers do we have an idea
it was it was above 4 000 which is at
the very least two to three times the
capacity for this facility Well look as
you know the immigration Minister Robert
generic visited the site uh with the
local Member of Parliament sir Roger
Gale at the weekend and I know it's a
priority now for uh for him and for the
Home Secretary to enable us to get uh
migrants out of that site you know
faster than they're arriving to reduce
the pressure that has started to happen
but of course I think it's reasonable to
say it's not going to happen overnight I
mean I've been an immigration minister
in the past
um there are no Simple Solutions here
they're very difficult but the
government is putting the steps in place
to procure more accommodation
um you know to start work it will
continue working with our partners in
France to reduce the numbers that are
coming and over time we'll be able to
reduce the numbers
uh in in that camp to what they should
be and in fact it was only relatively
few weeks ago that it was working very
well
um and it's it's when you say that you
said that the inspection report
identified problems dating back as far
as far as July did say that the camp was
was functional at that point it clearly
isn't functional at the moment I mean
the latest development is the prison
Officers Association uh coming out and
suggesting that we could be close to
riots within there because of the
conditions that that rather speaks to a
desperate need to improve the Staffing
numbers inside manston right now well I
think manston's not designed as a
large-scale Holding Center
but it's designed to have people there
for a short period of time before
they're then moved into other
accommodations so that's what the
immigration minister is focused on I
think progress has started to be made on
that but it's clearly not going to be
dealt with overnight but it is it is a
it's the number one priority for for the
home office uh and it's a very
significant priority for the government
and I've talked to both the Home
Secretary and the immigration Minister
about it and I know they're very focused
on making progress on a daily basis as
you mentioned you yourself were an
immigration Minister back 2013 2014
that's right yeah yeah
um you understand the the necessity to
use temperate language when talking
around this issue was it right that
swella bravaman described the situation
as an invasion on our South Coast well
look I think it's important for the
public that because the Public's very
concerned about this issue and actually
has been for for many years I think it's
very important that the Home Secretary
demonstrates to the public that she
understands the scale of the problem so
that the public have the confidence that
she and the immigration Minister are
going to put the appropriate focus on
dealing with it uh and you know there
are no easy solutions here but we can
deal with it when I was immigration
Minister we had a huge problem with
people coming in trucks
with respect we're talking about the
language here Mr Harper would you have
used the phrase and Invasion on the
south course well look in the immediate
aftermath of a petrol bomb attack on a
margin or nerve facility every
politician chooses to express themselves
in in the way that they do and I think
what was important the Home Secretary
was trying to convey to the House of
Commons that she understood the scale of
the challenge so that people at home who
are concerned about this issue know that
it's an important priority for her and
for the home office to deal with this
problem and I think actually the public
understanding that politicians get that
this is a real problem indeed actually
can help people feel reassured that
someone gets the problem and is focused
on dealing with it but that's actually a
good thing I I I get that but again
inflammatory language such as that has
been seen as an incitement to Violence
by people within your own party you
yourself back when you were an
immigration Minister were responsible
for those go home Vans and you
remembering yourself I'm sure very very
well the criticism that you received at
the time from people who had come here
as refugees from people who would come
here as economic migrants because of the
tone that was struck does the
conservative party sometimes or the
right of the conservative party
sometimes of a problem with the language
it it deploys clearly reaching out to
certain parts of the community like this
I mean you were you were pilloried for
this well some people criticize me but I
mean they're very clear they're about
whether the people who are here
illegally or not I'm very clear our
country welcomes people who come here
legally we provide safe refuge for
people fleeing from a war and
persecution you know we've had a
fantastic response from both the
government and the public for people
fleeing from the war in Ukraine you know
we've got 140 000 people here
there are no safe routes here unless you
are from Hong Kong Ukraine uh or indeed
Afghanistan the only way that people can
get Heroes across the channel but with
respect people who are in France are in
a safe country and we've always been
clear that people should seek asylum in
the first safe country
people who are in France are safe
they're not fleeing from France
um so they're actually in a safe place
and we've been clear and I was very
encouraged last week the Prime Minister
had an introductory call with President
mackerel and I think they agreed that
both of our countries would continue to
work together and would step up our
cooperation because we're only going to
deal with this issue if we work closely
with our partners in France do you think
France is doing enough
well I think I think both of both
countries Britain and France could both
do more so what we need to do is work
with the French they do a lot already
we provide resources to help them and of
course people will know that our order
controls uh in France are actually
physically located in France and we've
always worked in close partnership with
French authorities do we think they
could do more yes we could do more as
well and it's about improving that
partnership and that's why that
conversation with the Prime Minister and
the president were so welcome let's
let's hope that bears fruit before we
just get on to transport and on taxation
treasury sources yesterday appear to
confirm that we are about to see tax
Rises across the board is that your
understanding well look the Prime
Minister and the chancellor have both
been clear of the Autumn statement that
we've obviously got to set out a very
credible fiscal uh plan we are going to
have to make difficult decisions it
would be quite wrong for me to speculate
on those so I'm not going to go beyond
what either the prime minister or the
chances have said already but we aren't
look we are going to have make difficult
decisions it's important if we produce
an Autumn statement that is credible
that will mean that we Bear Down on
inflation more quickly and why that
matters to people listening to this
program is that means we'll be able to
have inflation uh interest rates lower
than they would otherwise be which
obviously directly feeds through into
people's mortgages so a credible plan is
going to require tough decisions but
obviously the chancellor will lay out
both sides of the Ledger as it were the
tax measures and spending measures in
one place on the 17th of November let's
go to your brief then shall we and a big
decision that you have to make it
regards high-speed 2 and the northern
Powerhouse Rail Link can you confirm
whether or not you will be upholding
what Liz trust promised at the
Conservative Party Conference that you
will be building that High Speed Line
infill from Manchester to Leeds via
Bradford so so two things first of all
on high speed 2 because there were
various stories that popped up at the
weekend the government remains committed
to delivering High Speed 2 on time and
within budget very specifically on that
High Speed Line between Manchester and
Leeds with that station well I think
it's fair to say as things that the
former prime minister said Rishi sunat
made it clear when you became prime
minister that for all the best motives a
number of mistakes were made and he was
elected as prime minister in part to fix
them so so we're going back to our 2019
Manifesto looking at the commits we made
we have got a commitment to make sure we
can get high-speed trains to Leeds
um and what we're doing in my department
and what I've been briefed on is we're
looking at all of the options that are
available to do that and I will and I
will be hasn't been taken no I will be
looking at all of the options to do that
in light of the decisions we take in the
Autumn statement and then we'll be
setting out our plans in due course but
you can understand the level another
situation and I've only of course been
in this job for a week so I've got a you
know we've got to look at this properly
they're big decisions we're very
committed to delivering you know what's
in the integrated rail plan and there
are a number of options for how we
deliver high-speed services to leads and
that's what I'm looking at those options
and decisions will be taken in due
course indeed so it sounds at least that
there is a decision pending on that but
another promise that that let's trust
made regards the Sheffield Bradford uh
don't sorry Doncaster Sheffield airport
perfectly good airport that as things
stand is now going to go entirely to
waste that coupled with that High Speed
Line could turn that part of the country
into a Powerhouse it is it is it
possible that you and your role as
transport secretary will look again at
Doncaster Sheffield well look Doncaster
Sheffield is also owned by a a private
company and they turned down probably
they turn down public money they've
they've um they've had some of offer of
support from from local authorities and
I know they're looking at some bids that
have been made for the airport
um you know that's a decision for them I
know my predecessor and indeed I've
asked the aviation minister to continue
working both with the company to
encourage them to look at those bids
seriously and also you know I've spoken
to local members of parliament and they
Aviation Minister will continue to we
encourage them to look at constructive
solutions for that airport can we
conclude our discussion this morning and
by referring to your former conservative
party colleague Matt Hancock I just want
to to read you this quote
um from the deputy chairman of his local
conservative Association I'm looking
forward to him eating a kangaroo's penis
quote me you can quote me on that Andy
we we certainly have will you be looking
forward to watching Mr Hancock eating
kangaroo penis
well I'm not going to say it on
television look on this situation I
think as a former Chief whip I very much
support the decision that Chief whip has
taken which is members of parliament's
first responsibility when Parliament is
sitting it is to serve their
constituents the chief wasn't that he
was the health secretary during the
Corvette pandemic in the covert inquiry
is about to start it is a complete
delegation of his responsibilities isn't
it to go away and mince around in the
jungle a couple of weeks because the
chief whips made the position clear
which is he's made a decision the that
going on I'm a celebrity is not
compatible with doing your job properly
as a member of parliament which is why
the Whip's been taken away and as a
former Chief whip I completely support
those decisions taken by my successor
would you support him standing down as
an MP well look he's now he now
currently doesn't have the conservative
whip so he's sitting as an independent
Member of Parliament what he chooses to
do in the future is a matter of him the
chief whips made the position of the
conservative party very clear which is
members of parliament should focus on
doing their job serving their
constituents in their constituencies and
in the House of Commons I would bet that
if the tables returned to this was a
labor politician you would be calling
for there to be a by-election over this
well decisions about whether people
stand at the future election for them
but the chief whips made it very clear
it's not acceptable for conservative
members of parliament to go on Celebrity
television programs when parliament's
sitting our job is to represent our
constituents in our constituencies and
in the House of Commons that position is
very clear I think my colleague will
have looked at that signal from the
chief Whip and the Prime Minister about
what the appropriate behavior is and I'm
sure the lessons will be learned by my
colleagues will you be like me assigning
the number to nominate him for a bush
tracker trials to your speed dial well I
think that will remain between me and my
phone I think
cover thanks very much thanks very much